Mark.
And three, two, one, action.
Season one
is a show about survival
and loss.
How it all starts,
and how everybody
realizes the new situation.
We are in the plane,
and we are traveling
with our group.
A bunch of people who were
not supposed to be together
who need to survive together
because the sun is deadly,
and they have to fly into the night.
The decisions we make
are mostly short-term decisions.
"What are we eating now"?
"Do we have enough water"?
A run, basically,
a race, against the sun.
This season
is a very different atmosphere.
We're not running.
We are staying there,
trying to survive.
Season two is about this group
who became a kind of tribe,
despite the differences.
And there are jumps
into a military context.
We are shooting in a bunker,
not anymore in the plane.
So we have more space.
So it's better.
Here we have
some good old human beings
who become threats as well.
Passengers from season one,
they arrive at the bunker,
and they think they're all safe,
and they are safe.
But we start to have problems
inside the bunker
because the passengers
start to do whatever they like.
And, of course, you can't do that
in a military setting.
When you're in a tough situation,
when you're scared,
when you're feeling vulnerable,
then you tend
to not trust other people,
and you tend to get defensive
and, like, go into your fears.
We're here to save people,
not kill them, right?
The characters are
getting crazier every day
because they have to deal
with lots of grieving,
and most of
the living beings in the world
have died just one month ago,
and they don't have the time
to handle that.
So they're getting more violent.
You have to draw a whole
new world of rules and regulations,
and some people are happy
about your choices,
and some people are not.
This is a military facility
under a military command.
And when an order is given,
it shall be followed.
In second season,
there's gonna be
more passion, more danger.
More speed. We have more tension.
We have more love, more emotions.
You're not going to miss the plane
because there are helicopters,
there are other planes,
there is a bunker,
there is a seed vault.
You take the same, you do it better,
and this is second season.